vous devez pas vous avez un rêve je peux
essayer de voir si je peux le réalisez
vous que ce serait qu'ils beinheim ah
ben moi je rencontrerai bien jean
dujardin je trouve assez charge du jour
moi je vais lui dire au revoir ses
pratiques en retrait après sa soirée
très sympa il alors après et en plus à
la fois je les bus il me dit tu sais
quoi
beinheim en ami ça peut être mon délire
exact et je vous dire que c'est pas vrai
que c'est pas une bonne sélection du
jardin ladam la fois dans la fois que
j'ai croisé des gens dans la fenps
rigole à tous les croyants ne croyaient
pas que c'était moi je les croisais au
bhv au rayon je sais pas quoi et il
croyait il croyait que c'était y croyais
que c'était une caméra cachée on y vient
avec moi il me fait mal mais c'est vrai
c'est toi une phare est c'est une caméra
cachée il m'a dit à un moment je crois
que c'est un mec qui travaillait la
génisse marine vannes ou un truc comme
ça
il était persuadé que je tournais un
truc au bac mais sinon je viens acheter
moi je te dis que tu fais une caméra
cachée mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
au sommet au bhv est gelée buriné et
janvier n'est ce pas là aussi c'est une
vanne tt qu'on allez vas-y du jour est
sûre la caméra cachée donc aujourd'hui
un jour ce que je peux faire
naomi campbell vous faites aussi non
alors faire le con
mais le maire omis je peux je n'ai pas
sur moi la e1 soir qu'elles vivent non
non non non ça y est c'est bon
non mais moi je suis comme j'en ai
maintenant on verrait bien david que
j'ai pas vu depuis longtemps donc
maintenant alors je vais me lever à la
fois où suarez j'aimerais réaliser une
belle audience avec le prennent que se
présente vendredi sur les marchés de
producteurs alors oui alors je vous dis
on parle d'un rêve s'arrête peut se
faire vous allez cartonné vous savez que
je suis fier d'être votre producteur
vraiment vous avez jusqu'à ont régi pour
vous où l'alcool est raté j'ai raté le
prime animaux alors des raisons qui
m'incombe
on n'a pas alors à coutadeur d'ailleurs
avec ses briques 6r mais c'est un de mes
préférés de l'année
mais voilà vous matthieu delormeau bien
entendu c'est mais c'est que des rêves
d'amour on peut pas avoir un rêve parce
qu'on fait les gros titres
non mais c'est pas par exemple moi mon
rêve c'est de chanter sur une scène pour
ce que vous avez dit que vous allez
faire un album
ouais alors là par contre voulait pas
les voir si je suis pas moi mon nom mais
c'est bon quoi s'énerver toujours robert
goulet avait reçue a toujours la nuit de
julien robert n'ont pu vous pourriez du
social c'est vrai mais elle n'était pas
insensible à son charme non c'est vrai
julia roberts
oui la connaît deux fois oui c'est sûr
que c'est par robert julien berger
[Applaudissements]
je prends des coups d'oeil où mon jeu ah
ouais mais sublime
non mais c'est du côté des lions est un
petit florilège des groupes plus beau
cri charger un souvenir de rien et la
chance de la faire et vous à chiner
richard geo bat non alors non en fait il
est comme les américains ils vous
donnent le sentiment il doit faire face
à la classe c'est extraordinaire oui il
a un petit kiki hollywood le sait on le
sait qu'il ya des gros a fait qu'on vous
croyez vraiment aux petits chevaux
michel des fautes mais non mais regardez
les conneries qui ni l'autre richard
gere genre tout hollywood ils sont comme
à ce souhait avant l'entrée des césar
ouais tiens mais la petite ils croient
qu'ils sont damas tiens à vous dire les
deux plus grosses si vous voulez un
catalogue wii wheel et one ewan mcgregor
et woody harrelson à oued a garanti que
c'est vrai d'accord mais moi je sais où
le don a les merengues est sur deux cas
vous vous avez des infos
c'est important à oui mais il a des
infos médias on écrase à plus pareil